how do you feel about making a film and
attempting to change laws with that film
is that something that was your goal
from the beginning or you just really
wanted to get these stories and your own
story out there I came to realize that I
don't think policy makers or lawmakers
really intended to create such a bill
the title chapter 4 title 666 that's the
bill that's in place for child support
and I might have got that wrong i might
have to redo that but it's in that light
that they created these bills i don't
think they thought about the devastation
that it could cause our society and I
think if they saw this movie they would
understand the pain that these men are
feeling or women there's some women to
that are going through these things and
I would hope that that would have some
effect because it's a nonpartisan issue
you know we have so many economic
worries and stresses right now if we
looked at the bill that the federal
government sends to the states according
to some of the experts in the movie that
incentivizes the divorce industry if
it's like 30 million 40 million 50
million maybe we could take that money
and apply it to marriage counseling or
teaching our schools how to build better
relationships or something different so
yes I do hope that someone takes a look
at it is it the right thing I don't know
if it's the wrong thing you know that's
something for them to do I don't think I
don't feel that the u.s. government said
all we're going to destroy divorce I
don't know that's what the film kind of
portrays but I let the audience do that
you know I want let them talk about it
and see him track down the law and maybe
change it create a bill
you